こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんトレーニングジムでトレーニングしたことありますか
僕も去年腹筋10万回して結構トレーニングしたんですけども
基本的には自宅でトレーニングしてるんですけどもトレーニング自分でも何書いが
トレーニングしたもあるんですけども
どれに鞭打って他の人がいるんですよめっちゃ設備があるのでいろんな方が
トレーニング
ミニいるんですけども私は思いましてトレーニングジムって日釣りじゃないわけですね
周りの人って結局自分の視界の中に入る状況なのでその状況によって勤務トレイのも
チベットか能力とかが変わるんじゃねーか雪私と泣いてるんですね
というわけで今日の動画はトレーニングジムで館
今日5パターンなら準備しました誰も居なかったら寂しいかもしれない人がいっぱいい
たらやる気が出るかもしれない
ムキムキな人が周りにいたらモチベが上がってもっとあるかもしれない
今日のどのいろんな状況でベンツだしたらどの状況が一番あるのか実験してくれたと
思います
ジャイ子
[音楽]
じゃああっじゃあかじゃなくて始めてくださいでは寺田さん入ってます
あれもいいなぁ
迷って来たそうですね長
hey
はいみなさんたちはページですはいはい
安居わかるか図っています是非はいそうですね
dj とこれを50機になるので入っ
に行こうっと
あよくすっ
[音楽]
最後できる
のん
はい寝ろ次が6時強
配当を1円
えっいます
あ
[音楽]
それでもれろクイズはならないと言いません
生まれ
いるいいあおらーん
ni
月光荘で今もず動きの
57.5ですねえっ
どうぞいきます
[音楽]
あ
お前男性は賛成
[音楽]
wh
今な残念ですねバッハ
そうですねうん彼も常に動きのがん
一つでも実現わかってきたんですかハイ3年使ってもらえん
プレイヤーさんだけ誰も自分にいない状況だと55キロでした
年か一つの基準になると思いますこの後15キロが
大亮といいんでした正直上がれば少数
一般的な強い方赤ちゃんが弱いん
た船なんか人がいた恥ずかしかったかもしれないんですけど誰もいなかったら逆になん
かすごいやりやすかったという部分はあった気がしますやっ次のパターンいきましょう
あ集めてですねくればいいんですよ
カズ先生ようなんですか
そんなことは何言ったら仲のいい女性
形でくるそうですねえはい
木を切った
を
[音楽]
説明しますお願いしまーす
いません
えって
持った
me
はいお願いしますあけました
お問い合わせ入った
ん
入った
踊りもっと持ってるぞ
上がりましたと思いましたね
うわぁわぁわあ6色あります
はい麻生じゃん
はぁ
ん
ぬりえ皆さん見ましたかこれが環境の力です今回女性酒のトレーニング詰めだったら
57点動き論わかりましたいい継承ですねどんどん行きましょう次
ジャアアアアアア
始めたのかと思います
初めてですはい
てしますしまうだろう
スペースのハイパうーんこの
女性はいないかといってこれはい
ありません
[音楽]
うーん
ホイアーよねすっぞ
費用ではないって言っ
じゃあああああ
ああああああああ
やってい
[音楽]
ん
えっええんおおぉ
どうぞはぁ
ん
んこれよこれ
地酒 ni
シラっていません
じゃ
いい頑張りが真山りか sera sera sera させられ
52.5ですね蹴ったら
の造営
持っているん
アジャ大手じゃああじゃなく所
鍋今度数で号でくるん
はい教育等これがでクイッとか
ちょっとなてなってこれだけじゃげますっっ
[音楽]
あ
すみませ始めてくださ初めてですよくベンチプレス
あがっていませんがぜひやってみます無火事ん
いますね
乗っん
はいわけですはぁ
あれは何キロぐらい9099
ああああああ
バッハ
いますっ
あるあぁぁああああああっあぁああああ
はいえーあああん
どっどっどう撮っ
はいえあしらせ業かどうぞ
うん
web 10万点5時57と思います
大丈夫です
いますはい
2月
ああああああああ
はいというわけで周りにも金利で右上の方がたくさんいらっしゃると
没後キロ上がりましたさっきより覚えノア切れてるんですよ
6粒周りの人がやってるとなんかモチベが上がっていこうとが出しちゃってもいいのか
なみたいな
懐かしかったです
つい
[音楽]
[拍手]
ファイザー
エイ
[音楽]
ん
はい女性が多いです
そうですね今日はー
me
ほぼ良くないことです
ああ
ん
[音楽]
ああああああ
持っています
ズームですなんだよ輸送船五式があった
いきます
ええええええ
[音楽]
usare
car
[音楽]
me
じゃん
ああああああ
はいっ
はいまよやりますね r
当然酒ていません
ん
おっ
th
ああああああ
voodoo
ええええええ
[音楽]
いい
もしやー
4ん
嘘2
もう少していますはいん
[音楽]
いきます
あああああ私を貼りますねー
ございます寝過ぎ60系トップスでございますぞ
[音楽]
ていません
全然冊ごと
いやー tame
goo
すげー
2そう思っ
uh
me
ありがとうございますまたね
そしたら110機を
てないの皆さん応援していただいてい rear
zoka な yeah
car
[音楽]
実ははいっ
今
[音楽]
あああああ
えええええええ
[拍手]
ua
はあああああ
goo うん
[音楽]
あと指で結果発表でございますん
最初のトレーニング自分に誰もいない状態だと
ベンツです55kg その後女性だけの旅日詰で別名ずしたら57.5kg ちょっと
くれました
鈴江で羊の一般男性だけの中でやると51ピッとキンググラム
されますねっバッハ次いで周りが認めて2戦だけにあった時はご中5kg はちょっと
増えました
のうりん4
水のそして最後には
ちょっと
60キロクレバー
[音楽]
[拍手]
たらやっぱりマギーのね[ __ ]
やっぱあると思います一人でやるよりもやっぱり他の皆さんがっ
赤ちゃんされて
まあそういう時に慣れた土地からがいい
fe てないん
よくそうですねはい
踊ら結果ですよね苦痛
ティーン
うって言っても大丈夫ですそうですねあプロ低温ボディメーカーに重要なタンパク質を
効率的にあの接してるし
ダイエット時の ao
ので
男女んね問わずですね大
いややっぱりメイクするときに
[音楽]
気付いする機会方は手順はせていただきますねーよ
はいっ
入ってあげて今回同 cad データプロテインなんですけどもこちらの前へ
booty んと言う
1日はずのプロテインですそしてなんと世界110カ国以上で提供されている
プロテインで僕を検出骨に結構脳天なんですけどもほとんど見やすくてとっても
美味しかったです
そしてなんとこの my property ウィークにエールをやっています
サイト内の商品ですが実力
ふうになっているみたいですそして今回このプロテインとしカーン
この2つをはじめセットとして生890円販売致しまーす
すごいそしてさらに次回に使える
ウエアの1890円分の割引コードをもらえるみたいです
主婦ブルーネットワーキングサービスことができるでキャンセル後の舞ポンティンの味
ってああすごいやつ女子60になったら滑落ピーっな強めチョコレート
や妻はなくてめちゃくちゃおいしかったです僕のオススメです
ぜひ皆さんキントリする交流次の方法を設けで周りの人の大事さも分かったんです
でいいととても金とみたいなのです
n one ん
[音楽]
ブーブー
あっちょ